un étudiant de 22 ans malik oussékine
matraqués par des policiers la nuit
dernière dans le quartier latin à paris
décèdent d'un arrêt cardiaque
manifestation s'adapte à millas mémoire
tension dans le monde politique
notamment au rassemblement des 10 ans du
rpr le ministre alain devaquet a
présenté sa démission ce matin françois
mitterrand au sco à jacques chirac à
21h30 analyser ce soir
enquête sur les faits réactions
politiques
dans cette édition
aujourd'hui samedi 6 décembre 1986
nouvelle journée de détention pour les
otages français au liban marcel fontaine
et marcel carton
jean paul kauffmann préval cornea et
jean louis normandin d'antenne 2 m'ont
toujours pas été libéré bonsoir tout ce
qui s'est passé depuis hier depuis
l'intervention télévisée du ministre
rené monory ouvrant un droit de réplique
ce soir vous l'avez vue ressemble à une
accélération dramatique de la tension
entre les étudiants et le gouvernement
voici les faits c'était cette nuit dans
le quartier latin jeune homme de 22 ans
est violemment frappé par des policiers
membres de la brigade mobile
il décède d'un arrêt cardiaque le
procureur de la république dirait
aujourd'hui que sa mort est due à une
décompensation cardiaque
créé par un état pathologique rénale
antérieur le jeune malik oussékine et
est dialysé
cependant plusieurs témoignages
concordants ont rapporté depuis cette
nuit le matraquage auquel il a été
soumis avec françois cornet et patrick
voix et le service d'information
générale de la rédaction antenne 2 voici
ce que nous avons pu reconstituer de
faits avérés
le massage cardiaque restera sans effet
eu malik oussékine gamou rires
effectivement d'une compensation
cardiaque selon les premiers éléments de
l'autopsié la victime a pourtant reçu
des coups c'est visible et de nombreux
témoins de la firme mais aucun des
hématomes subi selon le parquet ne
semble expliquer seule la mère du jeune
homme ait aucune fracture toujours selon
le parquet n'a pu être décelée à la
radiographie un point semble pourtant
clair il a bien été matraqué rue
monsieur le prince alors qu'il tentait
de se réfugier
dans un immeuble poursuivis par les
forces de l'ordre un témoin capital paul
baysse le fonctionnaire au ministère des
finances
entendu cet après-midi par ses
enquêteurs doligé est ce que nous allons
voir la police de polices formelle
rentrant chez lui il a essayé de faire
entrer malik oussékine dans l'immeuble
jeune homme a voulu rentrer donc cher
ce fait fermé donc j'ai ouvert ma part
pour laisser entrer et j'ai fermé la
porte aux crs mais cela malheureusement
avaient mis leurs matraques entre les
deux battants des portes ont écopé
chacune apporte complètement
ils ont pensé le poste j'ai résisté on
partira et
ils étaient 3 est beaucoup plus fort que
moi donc pas discussion possible ce qui
s'est passé à ce moment là et se sont
précipités sur je crois que sap
lémanique
je
comme m'a draguée copine et
moi j'ai reçu un coup de matraque sur un
thème les policiers mis en cause font
partie de ces brigades motorisées de la
préfecture de police se clôt quand
voltigeurs motocyclistes étaient
intervenus la nuit dernière le quartier
latin à la suite d'incidents provoqués
par des manifestants après l'évacuation
de la sorbonne par les forces de l'ordre
la mission de cette unité composée de
volontaires et d'intervenir très vite et
par surprise en impressionnant le plus
possible adversaire pour le déstabiliser
malik oussékine et petty le nombre des
manifestants rien ne permet pour
l'instant de l'affirmer mais il a été
pris dans la nasse et n'a pas pu s'en
sortir
un autre témoin raconte crs qui
descendait la rue sur les manifestants
qui se sont tirés dans la rue pas fou
que les crs sont restés quelques
secondes et puis on continue à les
poursuivre et à ce moment là tu es le
second a pris encore j'ai vu trop serré
stature de cet immeuble avec un mec
qu'ils ont littéralement tabassés de
façon extrêmement violente extrêmement
violente au milieu au million et de
tournées de tout le monde même si les
coudes sont pas officiellement la cause
du décès de mme annie causé king un
jeune homme de 22 ans est quand même
heure ici dans des circonstances qui
devront être éclaircies
une organisation syndicale de la police
la fpip proche de l'extrême-droite
apportait son soutien aux brigades
spéciales en évoquant les étudiants
maghrébins qui a pris ses
responsabilités un perturbant gravement
l'ordre public
mais les autres syndicats de police
majoritaires face ouvrière la fédération
autonome des syndicats police ont fait
part de leur consternation et demandé à
être reçus par le ministre il faut
rappeler des dizaines de policiers ont
également été blessés lors des
affrontements
voici la réaction de bernard deleu place
le secrétaire général de la fédération
autonome des syndicats de police
recueilli par agnès poirier et noël
alexandre ce drame est aussi le nôtre
parce que nous l'ignorons pas que ce
sont aussi nos enfants qui sont dans la
rue parce que nous sommes inquiets
inquiets pour la police son avenir et
son crédit sa mission et son efficacité
oui le tir tendu de grenade lacrymogène
est prohibé par nos instructions
oui frapper un manifestant à terre et
sans défense c'est se déshonorer soi
même nous ne sommes pas en guerre nous
sommes là pour faire respecter l'ordre
républicain
nous ne sommes pas là pour tuer mais
pour servir la république sa justice ses
lois sa morale certains ont joué que la
police
quand on est responsable on ne dit pas
allez-y foncez
je vous couvre pour s'étonner ensuite
des dégâts s'étonner que certains
collègues et pris ses encouragements
intempestif au mot notre métier est
suffisamment difficile dangereux pour
que les hommes politiques ni rajoute pas
leurs petites phrases démagogique
on ne gouverne pas la police comme une
campagne électorale
on ne politisent pas un service public
si nécessaire à la population
on n'encourage pas dans nos rangs une
minorité d'extrémistes qui déshonorent
la police déclaration de bernard deleu
place le secrétaire général de la
fédération autonome des syndicats de
police face au canal le disait il ya
quelques minutes ce sont des membres du
peloton voltigeurs motocyclistes de la
préfecture de paris qui sont mis en
cause par des témoins toute cette
journée d'autres personnes ayant
participé à la manifestation d'hier ont
fait le récit au pas de radio ou agences
de passe de brutalité dont ils furent
les victimes en fin d'après-midi le
ministre chargé de la sécurité monsieur
rêver à prendre et le préfet de police
de paris
tnet une conférence de pas souhaité
expliquer et justifier le rôle des
policiers
des bâtiments publics ont été attaqués
des actes de vandalisme contre le
mobilier urbain les voitures des
magasins des déprédations diverses ont
été commises plusieurs interpellations
ont été alors repérer je constate que
parmi les éléments les plus agressifs
beaucoup d'entre eux n'étaient ni
lycéens ni étudiant cours de ces
interventions plus de 150 membres des
forces de l'ordre ont été blessés dont
20 ont été hospitalisés la police comme
l'agent leurs mailles ont obéi au gua
nos jeunes malik oussékine mort la nuit
dernière est un beurre il est né il ya
22 ans à versailles est d'origine
algérienne il était étudiant à l'école
supérieure des professions immobilières
à paris et participer occasionnellement
activités sportives de l'université
paris dauphine
le frère de malik oussékine est le
propriétaire de la chambre qu'il
occupait témoigne à pascal deschamps je
suis bouleversée consterné
je suis encore sous le choc je peux pas
vous dire grand chose encore j'ai mal
j'ai mal
est ce que vous savez si votre frère
participé au mouvement étudiant récents
ont veccu tester un étudiant il était
concerné concernés par pas ce qui se
passait mais ce n'était pas du tout un
garçon violent
vidic il a fait des zombies de santé des
ennuis cardiaques
non non il avait 2
des problèmes et yvan de santé mais
c'est un sportif et il faisait du sport
assez
assez fatigant et n'avait pas problème
de 2k est un garçon qui tu le sais
depuis
non seulement je les loue une chambre
d'étudiant car il était étudiant et ne
parlons même parfois de ses études 6
orientation future
il était parfait comme présentation est
née politesse gentillesse de tout votre
soigner
d'apparence et jamais je le respect
qu'ils puissent apporter une lettre aux
militants de quoi que ce soit qui peut
pas tester contre la mort de sept
étudiants une manifestation était
organisée cet après-midi elle devait se
dérouler en silence entre la sorbonne et
l'hôpital cochin où repose le corps de
malik oussékine entre vingt et trente
mille personnes selon les estimations
ont défilé mais il ya eu les
affrontements avec la police dans le
xiiie arrondissement place d'italie
et puis devant l'hôtel de ville de paris
commentaire olivier werner avait créé
lake basket et roger motte un sit in
devant l'hôpital cauchy une minute de
silence pour une manifestation de dave
et de colère manifestation silencieuse
au départ de la sorbonne jusqu'à
l'hôpital cochin où repose le corps de
malik oussékine encore des dizaines de
milliers de manifestants dans les rues
de paris d'aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'adultes a su beaucoup de
parents d'élèves et beaucoup
d'enseignants etienne exprimé d'abord
leur chagrin et leur émotion
et à s'associer à celle des familles des
amis et de larmes dès l'étude du loup la
cité c'était pour l'avenir de cet
étudiant qui ont la glisse tout pour
commémorer sa mémoire et pour éviter que
ça recommence ou pourtant une nouvelle
fois des incidents violents ont perturbé
le bon déroulement de la manifestation
dans un premier temps sur le boulevard
de l'hôpital ensuite devant l'hôtel de
ville quelques éléments incontrôlés se
sont heurtés aux forces de l'ordre qui
avaient reçu la consigne de rester très
discret et surtout de ne pas répliquer
mais la pression était trop forte
les crs ont chargé encore à plusieurs
reprises c'est aux cris de malik est
mort assassiné chirac démission que
plusieurs milliers de manifestants se
sont rassemblés sous les fenêtres du
maire de paris
peu avant 12h30 le noir domine est en
début d'après-midi le noir des pancartes
des étudiantes en deuil et ce soir
encore les banderoles ont laissé la
place aux pavés et aux jets de gaz
lacrymogènes mais d'autres
manifestations en france aujourd'hui à
grenoble notamment avec plusieurs
milliers de personnes au travail ni de
silence et puis ici à marseille avec
masques blancs et
vous observez une marche et une minute
de silence à la mémoire du manifestant
mon ami dernier à paris
manifestation à marseille il ya
actuellement une réunion de la
coordination nationale étudiante nous
trouvons tout à la stalle gonzi c'est
l'instant la joie de rachid arhab
car le président de la république et le
premier ministre ont légèrement écourtée
la participation sommes européens
demandent le premier jacques chirac est
un v cet après midi à l'hôtel matignon
ou plusieurs membres du gouvernement
l'attendait rachid arhab oui pour
l'instant jacques chirac edouard
balladur sont ici à l'hôtel matignon il
se prépare le travail de la semaine
prochaine comme vous le disiez le
premier ministre devrait se rendre à
l'elysée vers 21h30 pour rencontrer le
président de la république un après-midi
h et chargé propre ministre il était
arrivé directement de londres à 17h30 il
s'est d'abord entretenu avec messieurs
balladur pasqua auxquels s'étaient
joints à monsieur monory et jacques
barrot le président de la commission des
affaires culturelles à l'assemblée
nationale simple réunion d'information
nous a tant fait savoir aucun
commentaire le premier ministre s'est
ensuite rendue quelques instants au cnit
la défense ou le rpr célèbre ses 10 ans
à 19h30 jacques chirac était de retour à
l'hôtel matignon était accompagné de
jacques chaban-delmas et de jacques
toubon
le premier serait donc en ce moment en
compagnie d'edouard balladur il prépare
je vous le disais les dossiers de la
semaine prochaine lundi en effet le
premier ministre devrait réunir un
certain nombre de membres du
gouvernement à nouveau et mardi il
recevra les représentants du groupe rpr
et du complet depuis dix ans il sera
bien sûr question du nouveau projet de
loi sur les universités
un projet de loi qui devrait être
présenté mercredi prochain un texte
considérablement allégé nous a fait
savoir denis beaudoin le porte parole du
premier ministre denis beaudoin qui à
propos de la démission d'alain de bach
et nous a simplement déclaré cela n'a
pas été évoquée ce soir à chaque jour
suffit sa peine
merci rashid le chef de l'état est
également de retour à l'elysée pas de
déclarations pas de caméras au palais
présidentiel mais avant de quitter
londres monsieur mitterrand avait fait
part de sa préoccupation jeu
entré dans mon bureau de l'elysée j'ai
trouvé documentation rencontré
quelques-uns de mes collaborateurs je
serai en mesure également de rencontrer
s'il le faut les membres du gouvernement
directement affectés à la responsabilité
de problèmes de la jeunesse et pour l'un
des étudiants ou de l'ordre public
en tout cas le premier ministre lui-même
informé fils qu'ils vont a précédé à
paris et que si j'ai d'autres
initiatives à prendre
parmi celles ci le fait de m'exprimer et
je les prendrai en toute connaissance de
cause je suis tout à fait moi même
engagé dans tout ce qui touche à la
cohésion d'unité nationale et je ne
manquerai pas à mon rôle ce que je veux
dire c'est que le devoir des
responsables et d'abord du président de
la république s'est payé à ce que tous
les affrontements internes tous les
affrontements entre différentes par de
la nation puisse étriper parier notre
peuple à l'assemblée nationale la mort
du jeune manifestant a suscité une très
vive émotion ce matin socialistes et
communistes ont demandé que le ministre
de l'intérieur charles pasqua vienne
s'expliquer mais on aura surtout
remarqué le ton très ému du président de
l'assemblée jacques chaban delmas
cette nuit
ajouté aux nues blessés graves
la soirée précédente un mort et
l'assemblée nationale toute entière
présents ou absents le déploie le depor
et je transmettrai un familier cet homme
l'expression des condoléances très
sincère
notre participation à son chagrin des
réactions syndicales cfdt cgt et fo de
la fédération d'éducation nationale
réactions unanimes pour dénoncer les
violences policières et demande pour
certaines d arrêt d'activité d'une heure
lundi prochain et puis dans chacun des
partis politiques d'opposition des
réactions confirmant l'aspect dramatique
de l'évolution de la contestation
la nuit dernière il doit comprendre que
la mort d'un jeune homme crée un climat
émotionnel tout à fait nouveau il doit
d'abord ne pas utiliser la police d'une
façon qui provoque le heures avec un
mouvement de jeunes qui est un mouvement
calme qui exprime simplement son chagrin
et donc il doit de ce point de vue
utilisez remplir sa mission mais à
remplir avec intelligence il doit faire
la clarté aussi sur les conditions dans
lesquelles ce jeune homme est mort nous
avons demandé une commission denquête
enfin il doit surtout dégager le champ
politique c'est à dire retirer
l'ensemble du projet devaquet écouter on
pouvait éviter ces violences si le
gouvernement avait su entendre ces
jeunes et ces lycéens des étudiants qui
manifestaient massivement de manière
pacifique parce qu'ils sont inquiets sur
leur avenir qu'ils veulent avoir accès à
l'université et pouvoir ensuite entrer
dans la vie active avec un emploi le
gouvernement les a pas entendus et ils
portent
de ce fait la responsabilité parce qu'il
a je crois il n'a pas saisi le mouvement
profond qu'il y en a je naisse actuelle
crois que c'est un acte x est mort d'un
jeune qui se bat pour ses convictions ou
je salue le décès en asocial s'associer
la peine de la famille je félicite
monsieur de maquettes de son intégrité
intellectuelle
il n'ya p ne croyez à son projet il est
démentie ne s'associent plus un
gouvernement qui refuse qu'ils laissent
la rue de cip est à sa place
et puis une centaine d'universitaires
ont rendu publique une pétition dans
laquelle ils souhaitent que le
gouvernement comprenne que les
changements dans l'université ne se
fonde pas dans la violence mais dans la
sérénité à la défense au palais du cnit
le rpr fête ses dix ans d'existence mais
compte tenu des événements tout ce qui
était bals et fêtes a été annulée cela
n'était pas convenable a dit monsieur
chirac beaucoup de jeunes des repères
sont partie prenante dans la vie
universitaire et le secrétaire général
du rpr jacques toubon n'a pas hésité à
évoquer le drame qui saisit la france
aujourd'hui le partage en lui de seine
jean corneille
comme tous les français
nous pensions
à ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans notre
pays et nous sommes concernés
attristé
stupéfait
par le drame qui saisit la france
aujourd'hui
à l'origine la manifestation se voulait
sorte de convention à l'américaine un
show permanent avec tambours et
trompettes vidéoclips et majorettes
seulement jacques toubon d'entrée a
refusé d'endosser son habile monsieur
loyal pour une fête à grand spectacle
le dixième anniversaire du rpr sera
néanmoins célébrer parce que beaucoup de
militants sont partis province tôt ce
matin par car ou en train et qu'il
fallait bien les accueillir
mais on sent que le coeur n'y est pas a
priori chez les jeunes du mouvement
l'ambiance pourrait être plus détendu
c'est vrai que nous sommes très touchés
par le drame qui s'est passé cette nuit
mais le gouvernement a tendu la main il
faut que les étudiants luciano compte
parallèlement à ça les 10 ans du rpr il
faut que ça se fête
moi personnellement j'avoue corps tant
qu'étudiant avant tout avant même d'être
un militant politique je ne comprends
pas bien ce qui a poussé les étudiants
descendent dans la rue
mais les fausses informations qu'on a vu
circuler dans les fracas de semaine qui
ont été véhiculées on s'est réparti par
des mots
l'épilateur des agitateurs
professionnels je n'ai pas peur de le
dire je les ai vus à l'oeuvre dans la
vague
jacques chirac a fait une courte
apparition en fin d'après midi sous la
voûte de la défense lui aussi pour
regretter que la fête tourne court car
obligations
les événements les circonstances en ont
décidé autrement et ne pas été
convenable ou naturel aujourd'hui de
faire la fête
puisqu'aussi bien il ya la manifestation
d'une quiétude d'une angoisse notamment
chez un grand nombre de jeunes et que
nous comprenons et avec lesquels nous
souhaitons dialoguer nous concerter
en espérant bien sûr que ceux ci ne
dégénérera pas dans une violence que
chacun ne peut que condamner et qui
s'est déjà trop développées
gâteaux monstre pour un anniversaire
surréaliste dire un député demain au
cours d'un congrès extraordinaire le ff
allumera les projecteurs de la politique
pour oublier
les mini lampions que ce samedi descente
enfin dans les réactions nous avons
demandé au cardinal archevêque de paris
monseigneur jean marie lustiger de nous
dire comment ils jugeaient à la fois la
réaction des étudiants et des lycéens
et puis les derniers faits plus
dramatique je ne peux parler quand même
de dieu un disciple du christ un mort
c'est trop et c'est trop parce que tout
le monde est touché il n'y a pas deux
camps en france actuellement ou à que un
peuple avec des jeunes et des vieux ne
vous a pas d des adversaires qui se
regardent en chiens de faïence qui vont
se s'entretuer il ya des êtres humains
qui sont responsables les uns des autres
un mort citron il faut maintenant que
cette mort nous fasse réfléchir tous on
savoir ce que nous voulons
il ne doit pas y avoir de génération
sacrifiée les jeunes en ont le sentiment
et nous devons le comprendre mais si
nous sacrifions génération si elle se
sacrifier un homme m c'est la france qui
perd c'est une femme qui perdant je ne
peux que fermier parole de du père de
françois régal la niña qui a eu l'oeil
crevé et qui ont eu ce soir de parole de
tous je trouve très belle où il invitait
les étudiants à la sorbonne à ne pas se
venger ou être plus fort par le pardon
moi je dis par l'amour je pense que la
force actuellement de la france est de
savoir s' interroger sur ce qu'elle vous
et sur ce que chacun jeu et la jeunesse
à son tour a droit à savoir ce qu'elle
veut le pouvoir l'exprimer en fin de
matinée le ministre de la recherche et
de l'enseignement supérieur alain
devaquet présenté par lettre à monsieur
chirac sa démission monsieur devaquet
s'était entretenu en fin d'après midi
hier avec monsieur de la balladur
quelques heures avant l'intervention
télévisée de rené monory monsieur
devaquet offert sa démission à monsieur
chirac dont la réponse subi n'est donc
toujours pas connue estelle bluesy
rappelle maintenant l'itinéraire
politique d' alain devaquet
la d'erreur universitaire du
gouvernement alain devaquet 44 ans
soucieux de l'avenir de l'université des
étudiants auraient sans doute préféré
convaincre qu'imposer chaque fois qu'ils
ont eu l'occasion pendant le déroulement
de la crise il s'est voulu avant tout à
l'écouté des jeunes est un problème qui
me préoccupe c'est que une fois rentrée
à l'université il faut pas que
l'étudiant père de son temps il faut
donc qu'ils soient bien orienté
physicien professeur mais aussi
admirateur du général de gaulle à l'inde
au bac s est rendue un jour de janvier
77 au siège du rpr pour prendre sa carte
tout naturellement les problèmes de
recherche et d'énergie lui sont confiées
jacques chirac décèle vite en lui
l'oiseau rare et le propulse contre
toute attente au secrétariat général du
rpr pris entre les feux des jeunes
chiraquiens et des vieux baron
l'intellectuel se sent mal à l'aise il
perd son siège de député en 80 mais sort
victorieux des municipales de 83 en
remportant la mairie du xième
arrondissement en mars dernier jacques
chirac lui confie le portefeuille de sa
compétence
la recherche et l'université et voilà de
nouveau le modéré aux prises avec les
ultra libéraux de la majorité
d'abord dans la sphère du cnrs qu'il se
refuse à démanteler et puis et surtout
sur la réforme des universités
une loi qu'il signe de son nom malgré
les points qu'ils ont tous été arracher
les points contestés par les étudiants
et que lui-même désavouant privé
paradoxalement alain devaquet devenu
l'homme à abattre le symbole de la
sélection aux yeux des jeunes incompris
il demande aujourd'hui à quitter le
gouvernement
tout en sachant qui n'a jamais oublié
l'étudiant boursier fils de boulanger
qui l'a été hier nous analysions
déclaration
oui ses conséquences possibles mais la
nuit dernière tout a basculé c'est vrai
hier soir à la même heure c'était encore
une crise universitaire ce soir c'est
une force politique
la mort d'un homme d'un jeune étudiant
dans une rue de paris en pleine nuit
rend désormais dérisoire toute polémique
sur les droits d'inscription et diplômés
même l'orientation
elle donne à ce conflit un caractère
dramatique et provoque on le voit un
face-à-face dangereux incontrôlable
entre les jeunes et les forces de
l'ordre
et c'est le résultat d'un grand
malentendu entre ces jeunes et le
gouvernement qui a pourtant fait des
concessions en deux temps premier temps
après la première manifestation
il accepte de discuter avec eux deuxième
temps après la deuxième manifestation
il retire du projet devaquet tous les
points litigieux mais il a mal évalué
leur détermination ce que les étudiants
réclamaient ce qu'ils réclament toujours
c'est le retrait définitif du texte de
vaquer le gouvernement bien sûr ne veut
pas donner l'impression de céder à la
pression de la rue c'est une question
d'autorité et il se dit prêt n'a encore
entendu à négocier à dialoguer mais il
ne s'agit pas d'un conflit classique
il n'est donc pas sûr qu'une simple
négociation plus le résoudre voilà le
malentendu le gouvernement ne peut le
dissiper que s'il décide d'anticiper
d'innover que s'il décide de surprendre
même la jeunesse merci paul je rappelle
rendront tu as sur ce dossier que le
président mitterrand recevra monsieur
jacques chirac à 21 h 30 ce soir à
l'elysée puis je viens d'apprendre que
les présidents la conférence des
présidents d'université adressé une
lettre au président de la république
une madame intervenir pour que la
répression 16 vous êtes aujourd'hui
monsieur le président notre recours lice
au texte de la conférence des présidents
d'université maintenant plus brièvement
dans l'actualité française et
internationale de nouveaux incidents
graves entre palestiniens et forces
israéliennes infra mal à en cisjordanie
occupée
au liban le cessez-le-feu conclu entre
les chiites et les palestiniens était
rond
moins de 24 heures après l'accord
réalisé sous les auspices les iraniens
et puis en france à lyon un vice de
procédure juridique qui a obligé les
magistrats la cour d'appel a annulé les
dossiers engagés contre 18 personnes
impliquées dans une affaire de
proxénétisme
ces personnes sont désormais libres et
blanche aux sports le tennis avec le
tournoi des maîtres le master s'améliore
certes le comté noix sont désormais
éliminés des demi finales mais ils ont
encore chacun un match à jouer à
l'apollo quand c'est un seulement même
attention à partir de 00h30 sur antenne
de retransmission en différé pour le
comté en direct pour nous à nous à lendl
de serre entre diana chan lau un petit
aperçu du match que contre nous sommes
là où tout sauf l'honneur à new york que
ce soir puisque l'on connaît maintenant
les demi finalistes de ce masters 86 il
s'agit de l'un des coeurs wilander et
berck ce sont les quatre premiers
mondiaux la logique est respectée le
comté noix sont donc éliminés non moi je
vois dans un instant face à ivan lendl
quant à henri leconte
c'est bien il vient à l'instant d'être
battues sans gloire par le selor
registre monde
manches 6 4 6 4 décidément les français
sont bien décevant dans ce masters de 86
5 matches et cinq défaites
reste à yannick noah de sauver l'honneur
ce soir face thaïlande l'inde elle ça ne
sera pas simple pour voit ici la balle
de match pour le suédois ministre la
mousse qui l'a donc emporté facilement
en deux manches et ce sur le service
dans les locaux qui avaient affiché de
grosses intentions pour son master et
qui aura donc que d'essuyer trois échecs
voilà que deux balles de match de foot
au dessus des lois a soulevé le meilleur
score face à ivan lendl bon gars et ou
sur antenne 2 à partir de 00h30 noté à
vos crayons pour le résultat du tiercé
d'aujourd'hui 19 h 14 ça donne vingt
mille neuf cent trente sept cent
cinquante dans l'oeil de 1730 3,50 dans
le désert
toutes nos cinq sens et puis notez
toujours les pronostics de pieds
adverses pour le tiercé donna à auteuil
dans le prix général du new pirette vous
propose de jouer auteuil sf le dise
maradona
l'as bram où il aime le 5 le câline ou
le 3 l'ami bluff 2 2
ankle leucate myard of le set enoch
d'heure le neuf et puis la météo laurent
un petit dimanche avec un peu de soleil
s'il vous plaît absolument nous allons
parler d'où cela parce que sans battre
des records nous vivons actuellement
deux journées tout à fait exceptionnel
toujours pour les mêmes raisons parce
que de l'air revient du sud sur dilemme
de l'air qui revient d'une sud-ouest
regardez là l'image satellite presse cet
après-midi par meteosat avec un
anticyclone ici du côté de la
méditerranée et qui fait remonter
des masses d'air chaudes sur la
méditerranée le puits une dépression sur
l'atlantique qui fait remonter aussi des
masses d'air chaudes mais plus humide
sur l'atlantique de la masse d'air
chaude qui viennent de la méditerranée
et chaude qui viennent de l'atlantique
nous donne des températures très élevées
nous ne sommes pas là pour l'instant on
regarde le temps prévu c'est à dire la
carte prévue pour demain avec du soleil
sur l'extrême sud est sur la provence la
côte d'azur la corse est une grande
partie des alpes un temps ensoleillé sur
toute la moitié sud est de la france
légèrement plus nuageux sur la moitié
nord ouest avec en particulier un ciel
couvert pour la bretagne et sur la
normandie attention les vents les vents
de sud-ouest sera l'amendé sur la
bretagne seront assez forts des vents
qui atteindront les 60 voire 80 km côté
température vous allez voir c'est nos
mains de septembre pratiquement avec sur
la moitié nord 9 degrés dans le
nord-ouest 10 11 12 13 degrés sur la
moitié nord du pays
15-16 sur le centre et puis vous avez
vous voyez sur le sud alors là c'est
carrément le délire 20° à biarritz et 20
degrés à toulouse des températures
dignes d'un mois de septembre
on termine avec notre agenda quand même
pour pas l'oublier demain sera le
dimanche 7 décembre
et oui le soleil se lèvera à 8h30 au se
couchera à 16h53 deux petites minutes de
soleil en moins sur la santa boîte
merci beaucoup paul audy régional de la
rédaction d'antenne 2 vous avez rendez
vous avec qu'avec claude ce ca à minuit
à demain vente d'un soir